quelqu'un a besoin d'un héros et il
s'appelle le roi sage et bâton jamais
entendu parler de vous c'est vrai il dit
la vérité c'est une légende vivante un
problème de démon c'est le temps de la
situation
mais craintes paysans désespéré une
centaine de démons et c'est parti
charmant que tout le monde adore ça qui
fait toujours hurler les mots à la mort
qui est le seigneur qui se dirait je
sommet qui ne vise rien
que
c'était un chouïa
embaucher un Roi Singe peut provoquer la
destruction de votre maison l'incendie
de votre ville des dilemme Moreau des
raz-de-marais des avalanches une chute
dans le vide des tempêtes apocalyptiques
et la mort le roi singe est en aucun cas
responsable des accidents ou des
blessures regardez à vos risques et
périls